foreign
is a game designed to frighten you
it depicts a biomechanical nightmare a
fever dream where everything you see is
a shocking amalgamation of metal and
meat yet under the foreboding surface
the world of scorn is a masterpiece of
Haunting and poignant World building
bringing to life a fascinating ecosystem
of Flesh and Decay while the game is
ambiguous by Design lacking any text or
dialogue a surprising number of answers
are waiting for those willing to look
for them so for this entry into the
archive will embark on an expedition
across this disturbing realm comparing
environmental details with Clues from
the art book to uncover the shocking
Secrets behind the Terrors on screen
now let's awaken to the nightmare of
scorn
we'll begin with a birth
the humanoid creatures of the scoring
Universe aren't born from a nurturing
parent but burst fully grown from an
unnatural wall and then plummet to the
ground where many of their stories end
as abruptly as they began the humanoid
protagonists you play as for most of the
game comes into the world from this
unfeeling system
after hitting the ground it's hard not
to stare up at the rows and rows of
ruptured cocoons and think about what it
would be like if this was the first
thing you ever saw this immense
structure referred to in the art book as
the Genesis wall is one of the most
striking Concepts in the world of scorn
dried husks lie beside the embankment
humanoids who perished through no fault
of their own there's a profound
unfairness at play that Echoes the
arbitrary nature of life one of the
game's core themes like many things in
Scorn the wall seems to be both
artificial and biological as there are
places where the outer layer Falls away
to reveal a mass of living organs
while the design of the Genesis wall was
conceived through stunning concept art
where the Wall came from is one question
the game's developer ebb software
declines to answer
the wall simply is a fact is immutable
as existence itself
beyond the wall shadow a desolate
Wasteland greets newborn humanoids as
they take their first steps cold the
field this is a kingdom of dust in ruin
a Barren land is seemingly stripped of
all natural resources through the fog
the forms of distant buildings reveal
themselves wind-worn structures silently
decomposing like the carcasses of
gargantuan animals
these haunting Vistas conjure the
imagery of decaying ships present in
sci-fi horror films like alien in
Prometheus the late Swiss artist H.R
Giger who worked on the biomechanical
designs for the original alien film was
a notable influence on the world of
scorn
some of the decaying ruins form vaguely
organic archways which serve as a subtle
way to pull players onwards one of these
thresholds leads to a cemetery of
machines where industrial vents Mark the
landscape like solemn gravestones at a
glance this industrial Mausoleum seems
as Barren as the rest of the field yet
defying All Odds a strange form of life
takes shelter among the headstones
seemingly originating all the way back
at the Genesis wall red tendrils spread
across the waists like an Insidious
infection and like hermit crabs seeking
a shell some masses of tentacles have
come to make their home within the vents
these parasitic growths are all that can
survive this unforgiving climate
to the side of the cemetery the largest
building in the region is a monolithic
structure called the assembly the last
Bastion of shelter in a ruined land many
forms of life make their home within
entering the assembly is like exploring
the body of a long dead giant the
hallways and cavernous Chambers call to
mind fossilized organs with the ribbed
pattern on the walls unmistakably
organic this biomechanical interior
design once again evokes the spirit of
giger's work in the alien franchise
where even buildings take on the
qualities of living things while the
bodily systems of the assembly have long
laid dormant you can guide the playable
humanoid to reawaken the decrepit
technology but be aware interacting with
technology and Scorn is never Pleasant
buttons and switches are fleshy and
bizarre to the point or something as
simple as calling an elevator is vaguely
unsettling and the more you explore and
interact with the interior the more the
original purpose of the assembly becomes
apparent the entire labyrinthine
structure functions as a kind of factory
enormous retro industrial cranes are
positioned to move cargo their
articulated hooks still sharp enough to
be menacing spine like Railways snake
through the assembly implying transport
carts once rattled through this area an
elevated control panel provides access
to a manipulatory claw arm like the
world's largest and most disturbing
arcade machine yet a question remains
just what was this Factory processing
the answer is the last available
resource in the world of scorn living
things
at the base of this world's
biomechanical ecosystem or the tragic
mold men these pitiable life forms are
the biomass the assembly is designed to
produce and are grown within hard shells
heaps of mold men husks have been swept
away to the corners of the assembly with
the size of these piles giving us some
glimpse of the scale of this factories
in humanity when it was in full
production the visuals of the mold men
are evocative of the work of Polish
artists the gisla beksinski a painter
who explored themes of entropy and Decay
beksinski's art was a key influence on
the look of the game with its emphasis
on somber visions of dried calcified
husks the imagery of a mold man sitting
in a transport chair with their limbs
extending out from the shell also calls
to mind the famous Giger portrait of the
space jockey this ambiguous visual of a
being seemingly fused with a chair which
was brought to life in the alien
franchise was a key influence in scorn's
development according to concept artist
Philip akovic the team found inspiration
not just in how the design merged
technology and living tissue but also in
its mysterious nature in the original
alien film next to nothing is revealed
about the strange being and that
uncertainty encourages viewers to
reflect on the visual likewise much
about the mold men and their connection
to the assembly's creators is left an
intriguing mystery
deeper within the assembly monolithic
towers of tissue grow in temperature
controlled greenhouse-like Chambers like
so many things in Scorn the purpose of
these looming structures is left
ambiguous with the mystery gnawing at
the back of the player's mind as they
walk in their Shadow a melting pattern
of what appears to be calcified bone
encircles the tops of these columns
suggesting they produce organic material
used elsewhere in the factory
the Legion of flying drones tends to the
tissue Towers every need hydrating the
chamber like devoted gardeners each
drone can release a steady spray of
chemical Mist which is noxious to
breathe in but seemingly critical for
the growth of the columns light from the
drones glowing bulbous shells cuts
through the Gloom bathing the chamber in
an eerie glow like dutiful worker bees
the drones stay fixed on their role in
this biomechanical ecosystem never
reacting to anything that passes by
foreign
epicenter of the greenhouse the tissue
towers are overshadowed by a Sinister
Central tree this massive organism is
far larger than anything else in the
region and appears to be the parent of
the unsettling Forest that grows around
it a unique type of carrier drone tends
to this Goliath taking vials of the
fertilizing chemical and plugging them
directly into the tree
yet these chemicals aren't the only fuel
source in the assembly even deeper
within the facility a strange structure
with branching pods seems to supply
energy activating this device will cause
the pods to open in pedal-like
Arrangements revealing humanoids kept in
suspended animation inside these
humanoids are closer to the player's
character than the mold men in cold mind
the living batteries seen in the
dystopian future of films like The
Matrix
the more you explore the lower levels of
the assembly the more the Interiors
become increasingly organ-like
extendable Bridges link up sections like
valves in a heart tubes twist through
the region like veins and some literally
seem to be veins a corrosive substance
analogous to stomach acid clears up
obstructions interacting with these
systems requires the continued use of
Technology scorn does include some
traditional video game items like keys
and weapons but filtered through a
biomechanical lens they become
unrecognizable a device that opens doors
looks like a fleshy worm a key you pick
up elsewhere in the game resembles
ringed vertebrae making it a literal
skeleton key to reload your main weapon
you approach this nightmarish machine
which loads bug-like ammunition into a
living starfish Satchel thematically
these visually disquieting inner actions
seem to examine the relationship between
humanity and Technology exploring the
intersection of the organic and
inorganic is a theme that's
unsurprisingly Central to the
biomechanical art movement returning
once again to Giger while it's easy to
just focus on the cool looking surface
imagery much of Geiger's work is meant
to interrogate whether humans are losing
themselves to technology it's a question
that in the Modern Age only grows more
and more urgent as opportunities to
interface with and disappear into
technology become increasingly prevalent
likewise in Scorn the playable character
themselves is changed over the course of
the game at various points in the early
chapters the player can spot a strange
creature scuttling like a lizard along
the walls called the parasite this life
form eventually merges with the
protagonist providing them with useful
abilities but slowly taking over their
body to complicate this theme the
parasite is themselves a warped humanoid
who after being exposed to mysterious
chemicals has lost their identity with
various subtle hints indicating they're
the humanoid the player takes control of
during the game's prologue While most of
scorn explores how Machinery can
assimilate the organic the parasite
storyline seems to explore autonomy from
a different perspective asking where one
identity ends and another begins
near the assembly lies a gaping Abyss
known as the crater a forgotten void the
depths of the crater are home to form
more dangerous forms of life presiding
over this nightmarish domain is a
gargantuan nameless Monarch larger than
a building the creature acts as the
insect Queen to the life that infects
the crater constantly producing new
forms of workers these smaller more
animalistic Terrors Patrol the corridors
surrounding the crater and take on a
variety of shambling forms according to
game director ludimir peklar these
beings are made from the same genetic
material but undergo rapid evolutionary
changes resulting in distorted
monstrosities with occasionally
recognizable animal features in some
areas flying creatures have evolved
flitting about the corners of the
player's Vision menacing you from a
distance all these creatures serve the
Monarch at the craters Center and will
rush to their defense if they are harmed
and most every member of The Brood is
dangerous with the largest creatures
worth avoiding at all costs like snails
leaving a trail of slime the creatures
of the crater leave behind twisting
masses of red tendrils these tentacles
undulate slowly and seem to be turning
the atmosphere of the crater into
something more comfortable for The Brood
in some places this malignant infection
has become as dense as a rainforest as
if an entirely new ecosystem is emerging
in these cavernous depths
in the distance a vast rail line
promises a path away from this vile land
if you reach the station the tracks run
for many miles but eventually the
railway takes you to scorn's Final
Destination the empty city of polis at a
glance polis seems entirely unlike other
regions with clean walls and elegant
sculptural architecture yet the more of
this abandoned city the player explores
the more you notice the darkness that
dwells under the surface
inside the central building impossibly
ornate murals depict unsettling scenes
with reverent detail these Twisted
tableaus show humanoids being turned
into something else the citizens of
polis seem to worship Transcendence from
a corporeal form with the destruction of
Self in ever-present theme in this
regard Scorn evokes the work of Giger a
final time as he was known for making
similar murals in the epicenter of the
room a bronze automaton beckons to the
sky above the statue's head the vaulted
ceiling is covered in an immense network
of neuron-like strings of tissue given
all we have seen it appears likely that
the vanished citizens of polis live
within this network having abandoned
their physical bodies in favor of a
mental Collective what it is like to be
part of this Collective is an open
question for those with within no longer
have the means to answer
yet this city is not completely empty
locked away in jars or the pale
diminutive homunculi artificial beings
who appear to serve as living batteries
like many life forms in scorn these
creatures were created as a living
resource their only individuality
determined by the shape of their jars
yet homunculi are quite intelligent able
to create an interface with cybernetic
bodies to overcome their physical
confines while in game you don't
encounter these creatures much outside
the rare boss fight concept art shows
the resourcefulness depicting them
assembling cyborgs like car mechanics in
a garage
although not cited as a direct influence
many aspects of scorn's World building
evoke the Demonic realm depicted in
Barlow's Inferno an art book by the
legendary Wayne Barlow Barlow's Inferno
envisions an infernal afterlife where
the souls and bodies of inhabitants are
a resource to be used by diabolical
ruling class while visually the two
works or in many ways distinct the
worlds possess intriguing thematic
parallels whether or not the nightmarish
realm of scorn is a literal hell is
largely left up to interpretation but if
a land is so Bleak that it's impossible
to distinguish from a plane of eternal
torment there's an argument to be made
that on some level the distinction
ceases to matter
but perhaps there is salvation in the
world of scorn in the back of the
central building behind a far more
biological looking mural a door opens up
to a long walkway at the end of this
path is a swirling Matrix of energy that
seems to offer a form of transcendence
before the threshold of the Nexus
statues of humanoids melt into dreamlike
strands indicating what will happen if
you step inside perhaps entering this
Matrix is a way to join the collective
the citizens of polis seem to have
joined or perhaps it is something else
entirely in any case it's implied that
converging with this Nexus whatever it
truly is would mean complete
Annihilation the total loss of oneself
is this really salvation or just another
form of Destruction I certainly won't
give away the ending to scorn in this
video but suffice to say the game never
turns its back on the exceedingly Bleak
atmosphere it's so carefully crafted
throughout its storyline
the world that scorn builds is a grim
disturbing land of ceaseless torment
there's a lot of unsettling imagery in
this game much more than I've shown on
screen here so be aware of that if you
plan to check it out for yourself yet
the world of scorn for all its alien
qualities is undeniably familiar from
the factories to the barren environments
to the droves of people losing
themselves to the Bittersweet Oblivion
of Technology the game is full of
connections to the current state of our
species and piecing together subtle
World building details and interviews
with the game's creators it seems that
scorn is indeed supposed to be a future
version of Earth where the catastrophic
misuse of technology has left our
species unrecognizable ultimately scorn
represents a worst case scenario for the
story of humanity
with all the potential this world has I
hope the developers continue it in some
form and show us more of their
biomechanical vision
[Music]
as always thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
foreign